here's an interesting thing so one of
the postmodernist claims is that
diversity is necessary and they make it
racial and they make it sexual they make
it ethnic and all of that that's
actually technically incorrect by the
way because I study individual
differences so those are the differences
between people and I know the literature
so you know about James des Morris memo
right from Google he wrote that partly
because he was watching my videos which
is why he wanted me to interview him and
I'm a believer that there are biological
differences in temperament between men
and women apart from the other obvious
differences and that they're actually
not trivial and that they maximize in
the societies that have the most have
moved farthest to producing egalitarian
states the Scandinavian countries and
that the reason for that is that there's
two reasons why men and women differ in
temperament one is biological and the
other is environmental and if you remove
the environmental variation which you do
if you make the stadia latarian you
maximise the genetic variation and
that's been demonstrated in the
scientific literature over about four
decades and no one wanted it or hoped
for it and they weren't biased in
looking for it because that was exactly
the opposite of what social scientists
wanted to find because social scientists
lean heavily to the left and what they
wanted to find was you flatten out the
state so that everyone has equal
opportunity and the differences between
people disappear that is not what
happened the opposite happened that
wasn't wrong and no one was happy about
it and no one's happy about it now you
can actually tell when you've discovered
something in the social science because
you're not happy about it
but if you take let's say there's a big
difference between men and women in
terms of trait agreeableness compassion
and politeness on average women are more
agreeable than men and the difference is
approximately this if you take random
pairs of men and women out of the
population let's say you had to make a
bet on who was more agreeable if you bet
that it was the woman you'd be right 60%
of the time well that's not that much
means you'd be wrong 40% of the time
that's almost 50% of the time so this is
a big difference by social science
standards but that's the magnitude of
the difference there are some
differences that are bigger like the
difference between men and women's
interest in people versus things is
actually bigger than that that's the
biggest difference we know but it's a
big difference let's say the agreeable
this difference but still they the
shared attributes of men and women far
outweigh the attributes that
differentiate them because you could ask
are there more differences within groups
or between them now the postmodern
answer to that is between them
that's why you need diversity by group
right that's why you need different
races that's why you need different
ethnicities and sexual preferences in
all of that well that's wrong there's
more difference within the groups than
there is between them you don't get
diversity by crossing the groups you get
diversity by by selecting across
individuals in fact the idea that there
is more differences between groups that
there is between individuals is actually
the fundamental racist idea it's the
fundamental racist idea which is well
let's say you're Asian Oriental to use
the old word to discriminate the one
type of Asian say from the other you're
so different from me that there's no
overlap between our groups and you're
also so different and there's so little
difference within your group that now
that I know that you're not me you're
not one of mine I actually know what
you're like no technically that's
incorrect that's wrong that isn't how
you get diversity
now diversity is actually necessary
because people differ in intelligence
and they different temperament may
different skills and so you actually
need diversity because otherwise you
can't take advantage of all those
differences so you need diversity but
you need genuine diversity and like what
would genuine diversity mean if you're
trying to put together a work team you
want enough you want people of
sufficient diversity so that they more
or less so that you gather together the
appropriate talents to produce the
implement that's necessary to work
properly in the world
that's a competence marker because
otherwise your business is going to fail
and so the proper diversity with regards
to employment is the diversity that
meets the the requirements of the
business essentially obviously that's
why you try to hire people carefully and
not randomly let's say